aujourd'hui sixième édition du printemps
des musées à cette occasion l'entrée
sera gratuite dans la plupart des sites
culturels en france et dans l'europe
entière et pour la première fois cette
année pour initier les plus petits des
animations seront présentées dans le
cadre d'une opération baptisée emmène
tes parents ou musées visites guidées
aux arts et métiers abdel ne s'étaient
pas parlés ricard courent si vite le
plaisir est dans le musée ce pourrait
être la devise de ce dimanche de
printemps la journée a beau être
ensoleillé la culture concurrence et
terrasses de café c'est une bonne
occasion aujourd'hui avec des enfants
gratuitement d'aller découvrir les
beautés de paris il va aller voir les
locomotives et voitures
les avions
aussi à wim aussi moi je les ai comptées
tout petits à comprendre qu'on continue
au musée des arts et métiers c'est
l'histoire des techniques qui défilent
sous vos yeux on peut se laisser porter
par le tourbillon des images ou
comprendre les principes de l'optique
pour ce musée l'opération est très
importante c'est certainement le
dimanche de l'année où le pendule de
foucault hypnotise de plus de gens
grosso modo la fréquentation annuelle
est d'environ 200000 personnes nous
espérons fait accueillir aujourd'hui
entre 3000 et 5000 visiteurs ce qui peut
représenter quasiment 5% la
fréquentation fait on un seul le
dimanche à vous désormais d'augmenter
ses statistiques passez donc un petit
moment au pied de la statue de bartholdi
rien ne vous empêche ensuite de revenir
à l'air libre